this is the story of how some very
special princesses and half a billion
dollars were whisked away from one
kingdom to another
it all started happily in the 90s the
Walt Disney Company was looking for a
home for its princesses and they chose
Mattel the Barbie company for over a
decade the little princesses lived in
harmony with Barbie and everyone was
very smiley the princess line grew and
grew reaching five hundred million
dollars of doll sales annually
but by 2012 Barbies sales were slipping
and that worried Mattel Barbie was
Mattel's main girl so she started
getting a lot of special attention and
the princesses felt neglected so Disney
called up Hasbro which had their Marvel
and Star Wars licensed Hasbro didn't
really make girls dolls but it had
rebooted My Little Pony to great success
and Disney was intrigued one more thing
natella decides to release another
princess line ever after high the
teenage daughters of princesses and
fairytale figures Disney was not
impressed so they went back to Hasbro
and gave them the license
the princesses got a little makeover
when the princess is left so did two
thirds of Mattel's senior executives and
as the glitter settles it looks like the
princesses may have just found a new
happily ever after
you